I'm Chef marinarani let's answer some
questions from Twitter this is Indian
food supporting
[Music]
Molson heart
treat Indian food is always served with
yogurt why is that yogurt serves two
purposes number one it cools the heat
from the spices number two it's a great
digestive also fun fact about yogurt
it's used a lot in marinades especially
North Indian Cuisine the enzymes and the
yogurt help tenderize the meat just as
we use vinegar a lot in cooking in
certain types of Cuisines we use yogurt
in India at Teresa on Twitter how is
food different in different regions of
India great question let's look at the
handy dandy map India is a subcontinent
so it's best to think of it as a
continent like Europe where even though
there's a similarity between the
different types of European Cuisines
they're still distinct and individual
North India so this is where the
Himalayas are the great mountain range a
lot more Dairy a lot more protein based
and also this is where the parisians and
the Middle Easterns kind of made their
way down invaded India bringing with
them Meats goat lamb chicken peacock
over here on the West Coast Gujarat a
lot of the cuisine there influenced by
East African ingredients think Tamarind
think okra was brought over the chickpea
is especially popular in the state of
Gujarat South India is tropical it's
humid it's hot food is funky fermented
and spicy so over on the other side in
the Bay of Bengal to Bengali Cuisine is
famous for its sweets these guys are
masters of converting milk into the most
incredible Confections you've ever had
at lemming0s asks can you explain to me
why chicken tikka masala is British so
after the British colonized India for
150 years obviously a lot of Indians
went to England set up shop in many of
them open restaurants some famous
restaurant here in Glasgow invented
chicken tikka masala Legend has it that
this restaurant here was trying to
figure out a way to use leftover
tandoori chicken he wanted to put it in
a gravy or a sauce that wasn't as spicy
so he used a can of tomatoes crushed
tomatoes added some spices yogurt thrown
the chicken and boom ctm or chicken
tikka masala was born at shefali Ottawa
what do you know about East Indian
spices health benefit I'm guessing you
mean as an Indian's not the eastern part
of India we were happily just Indians
and then Along Came Columbus and now
there's West Indians and Native American
Indians okay let's just talk about
Indian spices they absolutely have
health benefits turmeric is the most
popular and the most well-known for its
anti-inflammatory benefits turmeric also
has antibiotic benefits we use it on
cuts and wounds often ginger for
digestion black pepper for blood
pressure yes spices have lots of
medicinal benefits I mean look at me
just a picture of Health at the spice
tailor who had the greatest influence in
Indian Cuisine white people Europeans
Persians Arabs middle easterners India
has been occupied and colonized for
thousands of years but the most recent
and most important influence on Indian
food was probably what the Portuguese
came through the Americas and picked up
chili peppers tomatoes potatoes bottom
to India and transform Indian Cuisine so
it's hard to imagine but until about the
15th century Indian food really wasn't
that spicy before the chili pepper no
real heat after the chili pepper
just heat all the way at Cousin Carl why
is Indian food not more popular defined
popular that's about almost 90 000
Indian restaurants in America I would
say that America is probably the Last
Frontier for Indian Cuisine and most of
the rest of the world Indian food is
extremely popular in fact in England
it's probably the national Cuisine of
that country the majority of Indian food
in America tends to be either really
heavy or it tends to be really spicy
well that's not true actually of the
cuisine in India so there's a whole host
of young chefs that are now cooking the
kind of Cuisine from all over India
that's going to change the way Americans
think about Indian food at Pink Panther
yeah someone tell me why is this Dosa
thing everywhere because it's delicious
it's quick and easy to make here let me
show you so first you need a thick metal
cooking surface preferably a griddle
that's completely flat next Dosa batter
what it is is you soak rice and lentils
overnight then you grind them up and
then you let it ferment and then with a
flat bottom spoon spread the dose out
starting from the center you're trying
to get it as thin as you can without
tearing it and then with the sticker
butter come in and do the edges first
and this does two things besides adding
deliciousness it also helps the Dosa
come off the flat top easy and make sure
that the outside of it is that perfect
amount of crispy but unlike a pancake
we're not going to flip this over and
cook the other side you can put any kind
of stuffings you want on the inside
grated cheese spicy mashed potatoes a
leftover chicken from a chicken curry
and then once you're done you fold it
over not so bad Dosa given that we're
doing this for tech support at ASV
puddle why are these tick tockers saying
Trader Joe's Indian food can't miss bro
it's actually terrible whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa some of it not so great some
of it's pretty legendary I gotta say if
all the Frozen Indian food that I've
tried especially as a college kid Trader
Joe's more often than not nailed it at
a serving size of samosas is the same as
a serving size of Samoas right are you
talking about the Girl Scout cookies
let's set the record straight samosas
that's what it looks like this thing
probably goes back thousands of years
I've seen these maybe dope and on the
inside can be anything you want but
traditionally in India there's spice
potatoes and peas these smell like
aromatic spices so I'm picking up a
little bit of cumin a little bit of
coriander
do I sense a
yes garam masala at Deja Vu asks is the
correct way to eat Indian food with your
hands there's no correct way to eat
Indian food poor Indian families didn't
grow up with utensils if you think of
the knife and fork it's more of a modern
day European style invention yes so
traditionally I still like getting in
there with my hands the Roti and the
prata is a great vehicle for picking up
your curries and sauces but you can rock
a knife in Fork nobody's going to judge
you if you're going to eat Indian food
with your hands use your right hand and
try to keep the food below the first
knuckle it's just etiquette at the
editor in Chic wants to know is is there
a real difference between Indian
non-proach and Roti we all seem about
the same to me let's start with the Roti
the most basic of Indian flatbreads it's
the tortilla of India you just take
flour water Touch of oil make a little
ball roll it out cook it on a flat top
and you've got yourself a roti Paratha
is roti and steroids it's Roti with
butter or some sort of oil or fat added
and layered kind of like a croissant you
get a little puffiness essentially
they're the same thing this is the poor
man's bread this is the rich man's bread
and then the last is the naan it's
really a North Indian bread and it's
especially bread while a roti and a
product can be done at home anon's
almost never made it home this is
slightly yeasted usually with yogurt the
bread is baked in a 900 degree oven in
30 seconds and that's why non tends to
be the fluffiest and the stretchiest of
them all and yes the most delicious
dreamer while ordering Indian food what
else can be vindalude hashtag ground
props I like the way
just about anything you want
traditionally vindaloo is made with pork
the Portuguese introduced the vindaloo
technique if you actually think of it
the word is
vinegar and garlic that's how they
preserve the pork on the long journey
from Portugal all the way to India well
the place where they arrived in Goa got
a taste for this garlicky vinegary pork
and decided to add a lot of chilies and
chili pepper to it turned it into a
curry hence the vindaloo you can put
lamb chicken you can make a potato
version if you wanted vegetarian you can
put tofu you could put tempeh heck you
can even use peacock I don't care at
Frick karenin this is surely a very dumb
question but how similar are Pakistani
and Indian food I love Indian but I've
never had Pakistani not a dumb question
again Pakistan is just North of India
north west of India so the Cuisines of
that part are very similar in fact you
could say there's probably no difference
between kashmiri Cuisine and the India
part and kashmiri cuisine on the
Pakistani part there used to be one
country Once Upon a Time so think of it
as a region so the cuisine is going to
be the same Atlanta's child guys what
does Chase bison doesn't make a
difference unfortunately Starbucks is
convinced everybody that a chai is
supposed to taste like potpourri it's
not just get rid of the pumpkin spice
latte get rid of the chai spice just use
fresh ginger Mint or cardamom in your
child will be delicious however you can
use chai spices for baking delicious in
cookies and cakes at its Liam trefury
wants to know what makes a curry a curry
calling it a curry essentially any gravy
in India can be called a curry you can
also call it a sauce the term was very
recently invented maybe within the last
75 to 100 years became equated with the
term Curry denoting a sauce and then
also became equated with a spice blend
called a curry powder a blend with
turmeric Curry leaves and a bunch of
other spices everywhere you go Curry's a
different this Japanese curries this
Thai curries and of course there's even
curries in India now because we start
calling it Curry at Sana 2k2 which
according to you is the street food
capital of India hashtag Delhi hashtag
Mumbai absolutely hashtag Mumbai Mumbai
is the New York City of India it's where
immigrants from all over the country
come to work to live to play and to eat
and they bring with them their Cuisines
they bring it to the streets and kind of
like a DJ with putting together a
mixtape they mash up these incredible
flavors to come up with street food that
just is mind-blowing at Thunder Fishtown
we should know how a Tandoori Oven Works
wants to know how does a thunder oven
work well it used to be a hole in the
ground now they're above ground the
semispherical shape captures heat
radiates it back and creates a
convection effect that just increases
the temperature that you can get from a
limited amount of fuel so just like in a
pizza oven you can put in a pizza and
get it out in 45 seconds in a tender
oven none should come in and out in
about 45 seconds to a minute we now cook
lamb Chicken Kebabs paneer all have to
be managed really careful because of the
intense high heat inside you can't stick
it in and forget it you've got to put
the chicken in on the skewer then pull
it out let it rest and put it back in
and pull it out and let it rest and it
takes a long process to make tandoori
chicken that's why when you order in the
menu you got to wait 45 minutes for it
to come out at Charles Finch what are
the absolutely indispensable spices for
someone who wants to cook Indian food
for the first time there's probably 18
different varieties of garam masala
depending on where in the country you go
the word Masala means a blend and
mixture and the garum part technically
means warm or hot but that's not because
it's spicy but because these are
aromatic warming spices but the common
ingredients of garam masala are cinnamon
we're all familiar with cardamom the
little green pot that just keeps giving
black pepper a couple of grains of those
clove and on top of that you can add
some cumin you can add some coriander
you can mix and match these in millions
of combinations to produce different
flavor profiles at Spence raviab our
most popular Indian restaurants outside
of India serving North Indian food
unfortunately yes it is the most popular
version of Indian food in a America
bought to America by Indian expats they
were trying to imitate the kind of
Cuisine they were cooking in England
it's the food of royalty it's the food
of weddings and it's what's become most
popular in strip malls and white table
dining club restaurants all throughout
the USA at all your whs asks what's the
origin of butter chicken does anyone
know I always thought it was a modern
day recipe well you are correct it's a
very recent invention Legend has it that
the famous moti Mahal restaurant in
Delhi that claims invented the tandoori
chicken also claims they invented butter
chicken the sauce has got tons of heavy
cream tons of butter and that beautiful
Smoky tandoori chicken that's left over
from the day before what makes it
different from chicken tikka masala
chicken tikka masala is used with yogurt
tends to be a little Tangy a little too
acidic for me butter chicken is just
warm aromatic just delicious because the
smoking technique that just gives it
Umami to die for arguably one of the
greatest exports of India and definitely
one of the best selling dishes in my
restaurant at Stir It Up mag what makes
a good curry the secret to good curry is
thyme you gotta build the layers of
flavor slowly don't rush it especially
the part where you're cooking your
onions you want to caramelize those
onions get all the moisture out of it
bring the natural sweetness out of the
onions and then same with the garlic the
same with the tomatoes whatever you're
using to make your Curry give it time
cook it to where it's not burnt but just
absolutely packed with flavor at Zen
mode Premiere what's your favorite
Indian Street food and where have you
had it absolutely hands down pale Pourri
my favorite Indian Street Food it's what
I used to cut out of class go down to mg
road the main street in my hometown of
emmanager to have bailbury super simple
puff rice I mean think sort of Rice
Krispie treats small diced red onions
cilantro heaping piles of fit this
Tamarind and date Chutney the ketchup of
India and then green Chutney made with
mint and chilies and lime and cilantro
and then you just toss it all together
top it with this Crispy Crunchy chickpea
noodle called save and a little bit of
of Bill Masala and then last but not
least we're going to put the Puri these
wheat crackers I mean think of Roti
that's been fried oh get in there with
your hands and this dish for me
represents the street food of India more
than any other dish because every one of
these ingredients comes from a different
part of the country and all came
together on the streets of Mumbai at
Nicholas and Dolores is it like an
Indian food faux pas to put rice in my
career is that normal put your rice in
your Curry don't worry about it rice and
Curry are meant to be eaten together put
curry in the rice the rice and the curry
the lime and the coconut it's okay at
piri piri fries the cheesy vacation of
Indian Street Food why it's driving me
crazy I mean seriously like it's really
just processed cheese amul is the brand
that we all grew up with think Velveeta
or craft straight out of the tin we
don't really use this at home much maybe
in the occasional sandwich or two but
for some reason in the last five years
the street vendors are literally grating
it on everything all over Mumbai Street
vendors it's like a freaking zombie
apocalypse of cheese I mean what's next
putting it all over
how crazy is that oh
at subisha 2C do you know how many
varieties of rice they are in India come
on there's got to be a million varieties
of rice in India the most popular is
basmati rice my Grandparents were
actually rice farmers and they grew
basmati rice but if you're going to cook
a Biryani that gorgeous complex Indian
rice dish just layered with flavors and
meat and onions and yogurt layer upon
layer that is the king of Indian Cuisine
you gotta use Basmati so those are all
the questions for today hope everybody
learned a little bit more about Indian
food thanks for watching Indian food
support
foreign